[Musica]
[Applauso]
nel 2012
mi trovavo a san francisco a gestire
alcuni programmi per startup italiane
e mentre stavo camminando in alcuni dei
campus di aziende tecnologiche a monte
in via palo alto guardando questi
splendidi edifici
mi sono resa conto di quanto fosse
incredibilmente funzionale progressista
il modello economico americano in
segreto della mecca dell'innovazione si
basava su quattro elementi fondamentali
università istituti di ricerca
prestigiosi focus forte su tecnologia e
innovazione
la condivisione di idee
il cui valore sa cresce grazie al
confronto e importanti investimenti in
quelle ritenute più promettenti
un modello che fa dell'innovazione il
motore del proprio sistema economico e
che a fine ciclo deve restituire i
propri investitori il capitale investito
più gli interessi per poter funzionare
un modello che si fonda sulla capacità
delle grandi imprese tecnologiche
digitali di essere competitive e di
generale grandi profitti dopo
l'esperienza americana mi sono recata a
londra la città europea che investe di
più in
in in aziende digitali e tecnologiche
con 3,2 miliardi di euro investiti negli
ultimi negli ultimi due trimestri ma
anche una città che ha all'avanguardia
per quanto riguarda i diritti e
l'inclusione sociale nell'ambito delle
mie ricerche mi sono trovata molto
spesso a leggere di alcuni dati e di
alcuni ricerche che mostravano quanto
effettivamente la tecnologia stesse
avendo degli effetti negativi sulle
persone e la società sapete l'europa ha
sviluppato molti progetti che si sono
ispirati proprio al modello americano
cercando di replicare alcune dinamiche
della silicon valley nel nostro
continente
se pur tenendo conto della delle
diversità dell'ecosistema
imprenditoriali dei minori investimenti
e io sono sempre stata molto entusiasta
nel lavorare questi progetti che mi
hanno vista coinvolta perché credevo
proprio nella nella forza di questi
interventi di poter avere un contributo
sulla produttività e la prosperità di
questi paesi
quando stavo lavorando a londra però ho
iniziato a leggere di casi come ricerche
come quella che è stata condotta dall
università di pennsylvania in fila a
philadelphia che indagava al nesso tra
la depressione e i social network e che
ha confermato che c'è effettivamente un
collegamento causale tra il minor
utilizzo di social network e il minor
senso di solitudine e di manifestazione
di depressione in età giovanile
un altro esempio è quello della schering
economy che con i suoi effetti
aumentato il costo per alcuni centri
città perché essendoci più alloggi
disponibili ha attratto folle
incontrollate di turisti nei centri
città creando una distorsione sul
mercato immobiliare e aumentando il
costo della vita degli abitanti e infine
ma non meno importante le conseguenze
sulla privacy
la partita di controllo dei nostri dati
personali causate da modelli economici e
modelli di business che hanno favorito
molto le grandi imprese e di internet
lasciandole agire in quasi totale
libertà e tutelando molto poco gli
individui ecco ripensato alla silicon
valley vi ho pensato quanto mi ero persa
per strada ho pensato a il numero
spropositato di senzatetto che abitano
che vivono su marquez street o altre
strade del centro
ho anche pensato ai prezzi delle case
san francisco che hanno raggiunto
livelli molto elevati
essendo tra i più costosi del mondo e
costringendo alle persone che non
lavorano nell'industria tecnologica
spostarsi ad abbandonare la propria
città andare a vivere nei paesi
limitrofi
oppure ai cuscinetti sociali che
praticamente non sono mai esistiti in
california
e allora perché dobbiamo credere così
tanto nella tecnologia del logo e
nell'innovazione
mi sono mi sono fatta questa domanda ho
ripensato la mia missione come individuo
e ho capito che per comprendere questo
fenomeno avevo bisogno di lenti molto
più grandi
non mi bastava affidarmi al modello
della silicon valley
e allora ho provato a pensare ciò che mi
ha portato ad essere così entusiasta
verso la tecnologia e ho pensato ai
tablet che vengono utilizzati in alcuni
paesi dell'africa dell'america latina
per dare la possibilità ai bambini che
vivono in aree
periferiche dove non ci sono scuole di
apprendere alcune nozioni fondamentali
come il calcolo numerico divertendosi
grazie a tecniche di gamification oppure
ho pensato al progressi della medicina e
la potenzialità che ha l'intelligenza
artificiale di creare delle cure sempre
più personalizzate che ci permetteranno
di guarire da malattie oggi inguaribili
o di guarire più velocemente la
tecnologia net ha un potenziale di
creare tanto benessere per per la
società di persone però quello che ho
capito è che c'era bisogno di ripensare
al modo di fare impresa e tecnologia che
c'è bisogno di familiarizzare con il
concetto di impatto sociale ed
internalizzare lo nel nostro modo di
operare
e allora se pensiamo all'impatto e cioè
all'effetto che l'implementazione di un
idea a sul benessere della comunità
allora ci sono cinque elementi che
dobbiamo tenere in considerazione
la prima è che elaborata in italia e che
non possiamo sempre parlare di
scalabilità e cioè di modelli di
business che ci permettono di replicare
la nostra attività e il conseguente giro
di affari in maniera esponenziale
a volte questo è possibile ma ci sono
altri casi dove dobbiamo tener conto
delle peculiarità dei territori dei
bisogni locali e dobbiamo tener conto
quindi delle esigenze delle comunità in
città in provincia in regione
un'idea non deve essere per forza
esportata in tutto il mondo per fare la
differenza
per esempio se parliamo di problematiche
sociali ci possono essere soluzioni ad
hoc che si vengono sviluppate proprio
perché ci sono delle esigenze
particolari un territorio e delle
esigenze particolari di quelle comunità
che vivono in un territorio a volte
queste soluzioni possono essere
replicate adattandoli a contesti diversi
ma ciò che è importante è tenere in
considerazione e tenere aperta una
finestra al dialogo tra città tra
territori che cercano di risolvere
problematiche simili e modalità
differenti la possibilità di ispirarsi a
casi virtuosi e questo è possibile
creando reti tra città che hanno
dimensioni simili problematiche simili
perché questo crea spazio per
l'innovazione e la sperimentazione di
soluzioni simili diverse in differenti
contesti
il secondo punto è la sperimentazione e
cioè la possibilità di testare
un'innovazione una tecnologia non
soltanto dal punto di vista non soltanto
misurandone la propria stabilità e
performance ma anche da un punto di
vista sociale e quindi se vogliamo
introdurre una tecnologia penso alla
personalizzazione dell'insegnamento
scuola e quindi la possibilità di dare
agli studenti dei compiti personalizzati
grazie ad algoritmi di intelligenza
artificiale che tengono conto delle
lacune e dei punti di forza degli
studenti
allora dobbiamo anche tener conto
dell'impatto che questa tecnologia o
questa modalità a sull'apprendimento
sull'inclusione sociale degli studenti
sulle loro competenze
questa dovrebbe essere la prassi
altrimenti rischiamo di
incidere negativamente sul percorso
educativo e non solo delle generazioni
future
il terzo punto è la regolamentazione non
so se avete sentito parlare di
regolamentazione anticipatoria ma per
limitare gli effetti negativi di alcune
tecnologie dell'introduzione del come
tecnologia del mercato come ad esempio
nelle automobili con guida autonoma si
possono creare degli spazi senza vincoli
di regolamentazione dove si osserva
l'interazione tra queste tecnologie e e
con le persone e l'ambiente esterno
questo permette il regolamentatore di
intervenire in modo proattivo e di
regolamentare la tecnologia in modo tale
che non vada incidere negativamente
sulla società quando non è possibile
avere una regolamentazione anticipatoria
perlomeno la regolamentazione dovrebbe
essere tempestiva e intelligente cioè
non soffocare la tecnologia ma limitarne
gli effetti distorsivi
un esempio è la gdp arca è stata
introdotta per tutelare i dati digitali
degli utenti degli individui
oppure una legge che è stata varata
recentemente negli stati uniti per
regolamentare alcuni lavoratori della
gig economy come gli autisti di huber di
lift classificandoli come dipendenti e
quindi dandogli l'opportunità di avere
tutta una serie di coperture sociali a
cui altrimenti non avrebbero avuto
accesso
il quarto punto quando parliamo di
impatto sociale non significa essere
meno ambiziosi
anzi significa pensare che la nostra
idea possa effettivamente contribuire a
risolvere alcune sfide mondiali come la
fame nel mondo come l'educazione di
qualità sfide come 17 obiettivi di
sviluppo sostenibile delle nazioni unite
ecco allora se vogliamo risolvere queste
sfide complesse non ci possiamo affidare
esclusivamente alle macchine alla
possibilità delle macchine di elaborare
quantità in
tanti dati di darci delle informazioni e
non ci possiamo neanche affidare
soltanto a una visione lungimirante una
soluzione lungimirante di un innovatore
di un governo dobbiamo attingere a
quella che si chiama intelligenza
collettiva definita da jeff morgan come
un intelligenza di vasta scala formate
di collettivi e cioè di gruppi di
persone che decidono di stare a pensare
agire insieme allora se pensiamo
all'intelligenza collettiva per possiamo
risolvere problemi guardandoli da punti
di vista prospettive diverse perché pur
chiama tavolo comune designer con i
ricercatori policy maker con scienziati
architetti con filosofi perché teniamo
conto della competenza delle diverse
expertise nei diversi ruoli
responsabilità di tutti questi soggetti
che insieme possono risolvere soluzioni
in modalità diverse ma seguendo una
visione comune e allora se penso alla
grande sfida del cambiamento climatico
che vediamo oggi non posso non pensare
che servirà la collaborazione tra attori
con competenze ruoli e responsabilità
diverse per poter affrontare questo
problema il quinto e ultimo punto è che
quando ideiamo dobbiamo ideare con i
destinatari finali al centro cioè
inserirli in includerli nel design e
nell'implementazione e nella
prototipazione di una soluzione per
evitare di creare dei danni negativi su
questi soggetti
e allora soprattutto quando parliamo di
tecnologie complesse come l'intelligenza
artificiale che avrà un impatto forte
sulle persone sulla società e sul loro
comportamento
allora dobbiamo tenere in considerazione
a questi individui e attingere a quella
che dicevo prima all'intelligenza
collettiva
quindi per riassumere scalabilità verso
unicità sperimentazione tenendo conto
dell'impatto sociale
regolamentazione tempestiva e
intelligente intelligenza collettiva per
risolvere problemi di scala mondiale
infine ideare con i destinatari al
centro ecco questo è quello che dovremmo
pensare quando pensiamo a un idea anche
da un punto di vista dell'impatto
sociale
allora io credo di essere di fronte a un
audience molto sensibile a questi temi e
perciò vi invito a riflettere insieme a
me e di pensare all'ultima volta che
avete condiviso l'idea con un amico che
non familiare con un collega avete
pensato all'impatto sociale di questa
idea avete pensato agli effetti negativi
che potrebbe avere e come con chi
parlarne per cercare di limitarli
allora io vorrei che riflettessimo tutti
su questi temi e che vi facesse
portatori insieme a me di questo
messaggio perché soltanto così potremo
costruire un mondo migliore per noi ma
soprattutto per le generazioni future
che avranno problemi ben più grandi dei
nostri è soltanto così potremo sfruttare
al massimo i benefici della tecnologia
rimanendo degli intramontabili
sostenitori dell'innovazione grazie a
tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]